okay there is a renewed war against
abortion and there is a very specific
reason why I told you about this I told
you that this would happen as soon as
Donald Trump got his first selection to
the Supreme Court and it was renewed
even more strongly as soon as Donald
Trump got his second selection to the
Supreme Court Brett Kavanaugh the
Religious Right the social conservatives
the anti-choice activists they have
seized upon the reality and it is a
reality that they have a potential
opportunity here with this Supreme Court
to undo decades of progress on abortion
rights also known as medical rights also
known as women rights women's rights
also known as legal medical procedures
and the reason that they've correctly
identified that this is an opportunity
unlike one that they've had in a long
time is that we now have thanks to the
election of Donald Trump one of the most
conservative Supreme Court's in a long
time now remember there were some people
I'm not going to name names because
that's not productive but there were
people who in 2015 and in 2016 in the
lead-up to the 2016 election we're
saying I don't care if it's Trump or
Hillary Hillary is a centrist Democrat
you might as well elect Trump it's not
going to be any different well exhibit a
as to why that's laughably absurd and
malignantly ignorant is the Supreme
Court which now will have an influence
on American political society and
society beyond just politics for decades
is exhibit a and the abortion battle the
renewed abortion battle is one of the
great examples of that which gets us to
I mean this is all just contextualizing
for you that we now have had votes from
the Alabama House of Representatives and
yesterday from the Alabama Senate
approving a measure to outlaw abortion
in Alabama this would outlaw almost
every abortion in the state it would ban
abortions at all points in time in
pregnancy it would criminalize doctors
performing abortions with felonies and
up to 99 years in prison no exceptions
for cases of
rape no exceptions for cases of incest
this is a Dark Ages law and it includes
just one exception for when the woman's
life is at risk so this is meant to be a
direct challenge to roe v wade at the
Supreme Court level if things go the way
they want now you might say what why is
this happening in Alabama well yes I
mean Alabama is a more socially
conservative and religious state in the
sense that they want to punish gays and
abortions which are popular priorities
for the religious right in the United
States right now and of course it's
happening in a state that is a disaster
I'm not insulting the people what I'm
telling you is that Alabama has serious
problems to fix and what they're
choosing to do is to outlaw basically
every abortion the college graduation
rate is extraordinarily low in Alabama
they are dead last they are 50th in
education in Alabama they are 46th in
health care their economy is 45th out of
50 in the United States
opportunity is 45th out of 50 in the
United States
crime is 45th out of 50th in the United
States
infrastructure is 38th and so what do
they do they say let's ban all abortions
so let's break it down one step at a
time is this bill likely to become the
law yes sort of but probably not
immediately what I mean by that is that
it's been passed by the House of
Representatives in the the house in
Alabama it's been passed by the Senate
it's believed that Alabama's governor
KIV obviously a Republican is going to
sign it although a governor IVs office
has not yet at least as of five minutes
ago put out a statement one way or the
other but there's the expectation that
kiv is going to sign it so it sounds
like it'll become the law right well not
so fast this is part of the long term
anti-abortion strategy more than likely
if and when the governor signs this into
law there will immediately immediately
be a lawsuit filed demanding an
injunction and the idea here is to try
to get that case
all the way up to the Supreme Court in
order to try to federally challenged
abortion the way it will go is kiv signs
it into law it's immediately challenged
in federal court and more than likely
more than likely because this is such an
extreme piece of legislation the first
court that will hear the appeal may may
likely block the law okay a lot of legal
experts are saying that first court is
likely to block the law and that's the
whole point of this for the anti-choice
activists who want to have it blocked or
expect it to be blocked at the first
court challenge they will then appeal
the law ideally all the way up to the
Supreme Court at which point Bret
Cavanaugh's replacements of centrist
Justice Anthony Kennedy could be the
difference maker in allowing a major
precedent setting anti-abortion decision
by the Supreme Court so I've got to hand
it to them okay I think these people are
disgusting I think their priorities are
backwards they are dead last in
education in Alabama they are you know I
gave you the list already I truly find
these to be despicable people with all
of the wrong priorities but they're
pretty clever and they knew I mean when
when Mitch McConnell participated in
obstructing Barack Obama's selection of
Merrick garland to the court that was
step one of this long-term strategy and
so we've got to praise the right I mean
we've got to recognize good strategy
they were able to have a multi-year plan
okay it was a year before the 2016
election and McConnell starts with well
we should really let the voters have a
say before we decide who's going to be
on the Supreme Court potentially for
decades that stretched into the 2016
election and then Trump got his
replacement and then they negotiated a
departure for Anthony Kennedy under
potentially nebulous circumstances and
then in comes Brett Kavanaugh and then
they start with the state level stuff
and I mean they're better than us
they're better than us that's the
reality we have to understand that they
are better than us and we are only going
to do better than them
if we accept how good they actually are
and figure out how to fight against this
stuff so we'll see what happens with the
this could be the beginning of
significant precedent-setting abortion
related rulings by one of the most
conservative supreme courts in a long
time which if that happens the next part
of the strategy is immediately that
Supreme Court decision which may stem
from an appeal from this Alabama law or
the one recently moving forward in
Georgia then multiple states will pass
similar laws to this one and it would be
a massive rollback of abortion rights
and if you're surprised by this if
you're appalled by this this is exactly
what we knew their plan was as soon as
they realize that Donald Trump had the
opportunity of putting more conservative
justices on the Supreme Court and once
again it's already almost 20/20 if Trump
wins
he likely will get at least one more
pick to the Supreme Court yet another
reason we got to get rid of this guy and
we got to get rid of this guy right away
let me know what you think you can
follow me on instagram at david pakman
also follow the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show polls
behind the scenes pictures opportunities
for you to ask me questions all of that
great stuff we'll take a quick break
part two of my interview with the great
Cal Newport is coming up next